convinced a russian invasion of ukraine
is inevitable u.s president joe biden
returned from a weekend of briefings at
camp david armed with new options for
countering the threat it's very clear
that the russians have
no intention right now of de-escalating
the pentagon has put thousands of u.s
troops on heightened alert for potential
deployment if russia invades ukraine
american reinforcements would be sent to
nato's eastern flank poland romania and
the baltic states vladimir putin has
demanded those countries break existing
ties with nato just as he wants ukraine
kept out of the western alliance it's
proving how seriously the united states
takes our commitment to nato officially
the u.s is still looking for some way to
convince putin to change course russia
has tens of thousands of troops on the
border of ukraine they have the power to
de-escalate we would certainly welcome
that at the u.s embassy in kiev signs of
waning american confidence diplomats and
their families have been sent home u.s
citizens warned to leave the country
immediately
in ukraine experts believe putin is keen
to take advantage of a moment of
political chaos and disunity in the west
to get exactly what he wants
it's a pretty opportune time to try to
undo something which has largely plain
at played out on his watch and that is
nato's gradual movement eastward in a
private call with european leaders on
monday biden stressed the need for unity
and reiterated u.s commitments for now
that does not include any promise to
send additional u.s forces into ukraine
the biden administration believes that
combination of threats both sanctions
and an increased military presence send
a strong enough message for now but if
talks with moscow break down or fail to
progress the american posture could
quickly change
donna
okay jackson thanks